when I see a guy who's like I'm a boob
man he's like boob man he puts in his
profile boob man I'm like you got
breastfed too you're 13. yep you gotta
breastfeed a little too long Bud
yeah
yo what's up my name is Tanner everybody
knows me is a boob guy
[Music]
for those of you who are Petty this
one's you're gonna like this one yes um
so there's an uh there's an Instagram
post right a guy his um his name is
Tanner he posts a photo with his
girlfriend on IG some other dude Isaiah
Post in the comments a laughing emoji
that's it
Tanner's like what's so funny
Tanner and Isaiah then get into a heated
argument on IG oh my God good well
what's so funny they agreed to meet up
at a park to fight and then that day
several cars of people meet up with
multiple rifles and handguns and they
have a shootout until Isaiah the guy who
commented ends up dead it was a group
shootout yeah how do you get that many
people to agree with your pettiness on
the internet you both got a lot of
friends I guess if the commons were
public they could see everything right
they could see the [__] [__] talking
I'm team Isaiah yeah yeah and it
literally was as Petty as that yikes I
wonder what was so funny did they say
how many people were involved yeah I
want to see what was so fun did they go
back into the comments like yep I think
there was like it was like five against
five or something do they agree upon
that or was supposed to be one-on-one
and then they were they both had the
idea to Ambush each other it's supposed
to be one-on-one now a bunch of [__]
but they rolled up and there were just a
lot of people on both sides but they
were both so insecure they had to have
all their friends come yeah they got
loyal friends now but only five each or
four each yeah
well that's a perfect amount to fit in
the car
unless they have a Honda Odyssey or
something yeah one other girl was
injured a girls yeah but then she's
she's okay I think so wait which one
died the the couple or the guy who the
guy who commented with the laughing
emoji yeah The Roaster The Roaster the
roasty killed the roast did they ever
even figure out why he laughed yeah it
was just he was laughing at him because
uh he thought that the girl deserved the
better wait what do you mean does it oh
wait what he's he's being like that guy
you know that he's being that guy oh
come on dude like you're with him yeah
dude yes yeah
with this chick this chick's a [__]
10. exactly exactly you can do so much
better but all of that and then the
dude's Dead the Original guy Tanner who
um posted the photo is arrested along
with his one of his friends
and then uh Tanner huh Isaiah's dad over
this
that's crazy but he did if you look at
the actual like interaction in the
comments Tanner was telling him like yo
I'm ready if you want to do this and
then Isaiah is like oh okay like there
he's
he basically told him he was going to do
this and then the other dude baited into
it do they know each other
I don't know if they know each other as
well as uh Isaiah knows his girl oh word
yeah so they were local anyway because
of that sure yeah yeah it's not like two
strangers finding each other's addresses
I think it is like uh within that radius
where it was possible to meet up it's
not yelling at some guy on
Counter-Strike no which would be
freaking devastating if that guy fell
yeah where was this at this is in
Missouri
hmm they look like Missouri folk do they
really yeah they get down like that
these are the two guys that got arrested
yeah that's Tanner on the left Tanner's
on the left yeah Tanner on the left side
Isaiah no Tanner is the guy that that
shot okay they're arrested you can't
tell who shot who
dude well that's not the these are the
two guys that got arrested the guy that
got killed is this guy oh damn
yeah and he was the guy that was
laughing he was right dude Tanner looks
like a hot mess yeah I
think Isaiah looks way better put
together than Tanner Tanner looks like
he'll kill you first because it's the
monk shot he didn't get a chance to
shower and shave he's got a point there
there's a million Fly Away
Isaiah's Isaiah's picture looks yeah
that's [__] up dude that's some
neckbeard [__] that guy's like hey I
heard you guys got some [__] copper
in this room [__] yeah they left he's
stripping train tracks and [__] yeah you
ever made out with the catfish dude but
that's why you can't get in a fight with
the guy that looks like that though
because he'll bring his homies that
bring guns this guy he looks and what
about the miner Nick what's what's the
miner doing he's also a shooter too the
other guy The Miner yeah the guy next to
him
he looks like a child with a beard yeah
he's 18. he's a he's he's another guy
that I guess was uh may have also been
shooting he was helping us bro yeah you
know something my dad used to tell me
he'd be like uh because I'll be caught
up in stupid [__] all the time as a kid
like if you're really productive you and
you're focused on your [__] you won't
have time
for other dumb things right like getting
into arguments on Instagram and now I
understand
but even though now I understand and if
I went back in time when I saw like my
15 year old self I still would know how
to explain that yeah but they would just
be like yeah
exactly right
you have to experience it yeah I was
watching this [__] about like how human
evolution where guys are so for some
reason like at 13 years old they're
meant to start disobeying and wanting to
run away from the house because they're
like saying like it doesn't it's not
good for the tribe to keep the same
genetics so men need to leave so like
from 13 to like 20 something
it's supposed to be like guys are
supposed to go out and then find another
tribe or to build a tribe of their own
or whatever because the genes can't stay
within the the pool and so that's when I
think like they they measure
scientifically like kids and teenagers
stop listening or something to their own
parents like it's not just a rebellion
thing it's like an actual built-in
response right and like they don't even
tune in the frequency or like they're
literally not listening to their parents
so then
yeah I forgot like I didn't watch the
whole video but that really struck out
to me like oh [__] 13 years old that's
around the time I started fighting so I
got bored in it yeah I just kind of so
my ADHD acted up and I started [__]
grilling chicken wings right and I
[__] probably started watching
another video of a girl shaking the end
of that video was like by the way none
of this
can be used in any
so please don't repeat it yeah but my
severe delinquency started around 13ish
so it was the same age same time when I
just started like thinking my parents
were stupid they don't know what they're
talking about yeah yeah yeah I basically
left home from like 16 on I would do
whatever I could like girlfriend improv
friends just whatever got me the [__]
out of the house I would do yeah there's
definitely a lot of weirdness that does
come from people that stayed at home a
little too long too yes 100 social
skills especially yeah especially guys
that are like I think like
so I might be butchering this
explanation but so Mama's Boys right
guys that don't disobey their parents
and break through and find their
independence they're really weird to me
because there's one thing to respect
your mother and love her and they've
always been breastfeeding until like
nine years old yeah but like when you
when you're like
when you're completely powerless and you
obey everything you don't challenge your
parents something's [__] wrong with
you something's wrong yeah when I see a
guy who's like I'm a boob man boob man
he puts in his profile boob man I'm like
you got breastfed too you're 13. yep you
gotta breastfed a little too long bud
I'm a [__] boob man yeah it's an
Instagram
yo what's up my name is Tanner everybody
knows me is a boob guy I wear
Quicksilver and I'm a boob guy no thanks
for sharing dating shows yeah yeah it's
next
but you know what's funny is like I feel
like throughout life the way this other
kid is arrested over his friend's [__]
that could have happened to any of us
like that yeah we were idiots yeah hell
yeah my friend told me I'm gonna go
fight back then I would have been like
let's go dude I went forking for my
buddy no problem we forked all of the
chicks who rejected him that was the
best part it was one of the funniest
things about it because like if a chick
rejected him we would Fork them and then
like let's be clear what that actually
is though oh yeah we would um hold them
down and have sex with their bodies my
God if they didn't want to because right
no forking is when you
you buy plastic forks and you stick them
in their lawn it's the most innocent
crime ever you stick them you stick them
to their lawn so that the plastic butt
goes in and the fork is sticking out
because it looks funny and then we would
like go to Costco and spend like 45 dude
you guys are like Zen gardeners oh yeah
dude we would like literally you would
see dude as far as I can see it says how
long would it take you to do one house
we could do in like 15 minutes
I was just me and my buddy because like
yeah because there's losers on a
Saturday night
yeah but then like the best part was
that it was just chicks who rejected
this guy and like I didn't have
a brag in here I just didn't have tricks
that rejected me I had like I was always
like a dedicated girlfriend guy yeah so
I would just have one girl for like a
very long period of time so I just
didn't like take many shots and this guy
just kept on shooting way over his
[__] head right and so yeah he did
plenty of she went to the nuclear power
plant smart smart move no but he had a
whole list and so then we would we were
doing individual forking and then one
night we had this idea we called it
because San Diego are you guys split up
the San Diego Zoo has this thing called
the Festival of Lights and so we did
this thing because we're in San Diego we
called it the Festival of forks where we
hit every house of all the chicks that
rejected him in one night but if that's
not in cell [__] I don't know what the
[__] is that's pretty funny yeah so then
that's the best part is I was laughing
so hard the entire time I can't believe
that the dads didn't come turn on light
and come outside because I was laughing
my ass off because I just couldn't
believe how [__] infantile and stupid
and Petty this was that is really
ridiculous yeah you know it's funny
speaking of like having to explain
yourself there's I don't know if you saw
this there's somebody uh in our comments
who when you were bragging about how you
were in a high school play and that the
reviews were in
there's someone who really believes
yourself yeah and they and they're in
the comments what an idiot it's just a
high school play he's so cocky about his
theater life it's insane that's so
devastating I'm so sorry for you that
was my burner account
[Laughter]
he's so funny High School you just go on
your YouTube channel anytime he talks
cocky big game you just talk [__] like I
can't believe he actually believes in
this well there was several there's
somebody who wrote something about
Anthony and then I just it it was so
like like I love Anthony and his his
dancing thing gave me so much confidence
and I was like hi Anthony's Burger
account
but I made
was I posted that from another account
that I made so that it has my icon for
like my picture my face and [__] but it
was clearly my burner account that's
what the joke was to me but then you
never know how these people you're using
your own fit stuff yeah yeah yeah but
you never know because yeah goddamn dude
I can't believe it the reviews are in is
the joke the reviews are in is that's
the entire Crux of the joke that's why
anyone laughed it's because who gives a
[__] about high school Theory a [__]
idiot go get a friend one friend start
with blood
[Music]